[Music]
hey
now i'm quiet
[Music]
oh
so
just setting up one second guys
shouldn't have clicked live so early
ah
the music sound now there's absolutely
nothing
am i live even no there's no one here
okay good
[Music]
um
i am inviting some players right now
[Music]
and they're all confused because they
haven't seen the live stream i'm just
i would rather set up before i'm
actually live
[Music]
so not everyone had to wait
even though they are probably waiting
for the stream
[Music]
nearly there oh my minecraft crashed
dang it
[Music]
okay
this is probably a very boring live
stream if anyone's watching it
no no one's found it i don't know why
why not no notification
well if you're watching the vod just
skip ahead my dude
[Music]
huh
oh the game crashed why
it's obs that does it and i don't know
why
[Music]
that when your username shows up it
always confuses me i'm like what the
[ __ ] is that
[Music]
do
all right i'm gonna switch this to
public
[Music]
anyone in here hello
i know you're there there we go what's
up kate
playing minecraft with you guys today
again
[Music]
for those who don't you who don't know
signing up with awesome partner
party link is in the description
if you want to play with me today use
the link
sign up and create a party
with the hashtag partygang
that way i will find it and i will
invite you guys and i've already used it
for people that are early but i'll
switch out as i go
uh party is an app that helps you
connect with other gamers
you know how hard it is to find good
gamers out there but you know they're
out there
it's really nifty it's really cool um
keep it's fun keep it safe
[Music]
any game anytime there's a gamer out
there who wants a game with you
i don't have any party sign up for party
all right
so yeah let's get this uh party started
get it party
it's tinder for gaming i don't know
about that
all right so if your name is m
kerish mr g once raptorini jackson the
great
the third chocolate bro and the red
glasses you better be in the stream
right now because we're starting a game
together
well i'm curious is there i see you i
see you
okay i'm just going to start it
how do i start it
i'm downloading it that's why my face is
red because the mojang logo pops up
so glad i spent those five dollars
hey you guys are quick
are you allowed to steam yes
let me turn up the game volume
no i got it i got it all right so this
is arrow wars i never play this have you
guys played this
no good because i have no idea what the
[ __ ]
all right well i'm team red
okay we got a bunch of minecraft noobs
here well you can't oh pick my team
all right we got two red everyone else
go go blue
and chris go blue mr go blue
god bless you
mr g1 blue team
huh get over there get over here
hey skedaddle blue
go blue team pick blue team
team
here there go there go
there go there where i am karish is
standing go there
oh jackson the great joy nice welcome
welcome welcome hey jackson blue team
welcome
jackson yeah jackson's got it hell yeah
all right mister if you don't pick a
team
all right yeah sorry i didn't give you
guys heads up
oh yeah okay nice sorry for yelling at
you i was just joking
all right so two versus three is that
fair it's okay it's okay i was just
trolling
yeah i do remember yeah [ __ ] you guys uh
yeah more people will join let's just
start i just wanted to start
all right shop we can get a
pickaxe what what is this how do i play
this i have no idea
oh god it's one of these are like
[ __ ] it i'll use my axe
is that them look at look how scared
they are
did my face cam i think the dogs pull
out my uh camera they keep doing it
you don't know how this works trust me
no one work knows
i think we're supposed to kill each
other that's usually how these go
i have the super laggy
i think you mined a tower for blocks uh
yeah you can also mine the stairs if
you're pro
what i can't there we go
why am i collecting don't don't question
my minecraft strategies i know exactly
what i'm doing
i'll put the face cam in as soon as this
round is over
they literally just pull out the hdmi
cable it's like hovering above
their little bed can i do this then
no yeah i can this is laggy there we go
oh sorry after i wasn't trying to murder
you hey raptor director let's go
we got an n there's diamonds down there
wait i can't place blocks between
only on our side so we can only build
like a shield
all right sorry guys we're switching
modes this [ __ ] sucks
hold up
you pull out the cable
huh
did it work
cables flying left and right
you see them
look at them all squished up my
so edgar is in the bed right now but
maya is like no
it's my bed so she just lays on top of
him
all right let's switch mode
i thought arrow was like oh that's cool
arrow like you shoot each other no
which was the one we played some really
fun ones last time
uh which one was it
there's would you rather
i don't remember the names of them
i think i guess we can just pick one
what is this
sprint racer that sounds cool
all right i'm starting that
if i had to pick a different career
tomorrow what would it be
uh woodcutter so i can real life
minecraft
it's taking a long time to connect
hey enderlord 100 chf thank you
thank you damn felix your hair looks
epic lately
thank you marcel cuts my hair
it's that wife haircut gang
all right what what happened
oh here we go i'm in all right
not sure what the she says
ah
so loud
why
okay well what the [ __ ] is this then
some sonic [ __ ] oh i'm so fast
what do i do i don't know
[Laughter]
how to play okay sprint along the track
and reach the finish before your
opponents most tracks have multiple laps
okay you must hit checkpoints in order
okay
all right but how do we start it
can we turn off the music it's great but
no
we promote the music instead
for your safety
no i like the fob it's making me trip
out
has it started i'm oh okay guys
get the traffic light in your hand and
hit ready
where's the start then oh
are we going what is happening
oh you have to vote for a map as well
it's a tutorial no i vote for two row
two
okay here we go whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
yes this is the field of view is awful
here we go
am i winning i don't know i am winning
ah
no i got us something slime
slime no mr g1
stop it
all right i like the music can you feel
the sunshine
the electric snowball shoot him i missed
hey g1 slow down slow down my dude yes
yes it worked
no not the water [ __ ] [ __ ] slime them
slime them
g1 there's a tnt chicken get him get him
get him get him go chicken goat you can
go chicken goat chicken
ah no no
what how am i fourth get out of here
that's all right you can pop in next
round red glasses
i don't realize other people had to buy
it i thought only i had
i keep [ __ ]
[Applause]
sword yes kill him
kill him come here what does this do
what am i going to do with a
okay jumping does not help
final lap this
is true that's the fourth time i made
that mistake
wait elytra it did nothing but slow me
down
i'm holding left oh control i know that
how did i get progressively worse
okay i got speed boost
oh my god did i come last
i came last wow
congratulations raptorini
you were last and chris wait you weren't
really
oh yeah sorry i meant to rub you in it
hey that's fun i like that
all right so yeah i'm going to change
out
new players if you sign up with party
link in the description i'll pick new
ones
i know everyone wants to play bed wars
but i ain't touching that [ __ ] oh sakura
[ __ ]
sakura city [ __ ] let's do sakura city
and let me change this [ __ ] field of
view my god
where is it
what did they recommend that was
nauseating dude
okay here we go hopefully i don't throw
up
i haven't had am i not running where am
i going
wow it's like i am in japan wow
not as much speed in this one but we can
do it
wow i guess i'm going here i don't
i don't know where i'm supposed to go to
be honest
okay
all right what do i get sword okay
no i should have jumped okay
is that one lap nice
give me more items apple
heals me don't need that [ __ ] my sword
ran out
uh it was a trap
what the hell that did nothing
[Applause]
got him all right let's remember to jump
here it's coming up
invisibility
that was sick
low-key like this game mode i'm the fast
as [ __ ] boy oh when can i miss a
launcher no
no no no no no no no no
i shot you with a missile launcher yeah
[ __ ]
hey no second third
how how
oh don't mess this up now
come on eat it
it was a trap i fell for the trap no
jackson yeah
are you serious the final lap you pull
that
[ __ ] that's some [ __ ]
you missed the checkpoint yeah this map
was confusing i don't know where i was
going
i thought we had that in the bag man
hell yeah i'm glad you enjoyed it it's
fun
all right i'll win the next one don't
worry this is almost chaotic
why don't f me
uh who was not who was not finished
emcrash
em grace you gotta finish
[Music]
where are you stop typing start running
there you are you're going the wrong way
okay
fine you know it doesn't matter
all right there we go
oof
all right one more race guys and then
i'll swap out
oh road roller let's see that
what else we got frostbite coastal
field of view effects ah what does that
mean
i never heard of effects
this map [ __ ] looks more straightforward
that's all right
all right here we go ah
run six really
third three three sec hey come on
lag advantage come on
ow don't do that thank you that actually
helped
resistance okay
the music was so loud when you first
joined but i'm kind of vibing it's nice
hopefully it's not copyrighted
missile launcher all right
you guys are never going to catch up now
i'm too strong
checking mine [ __ ] i
go checking mine
[Music]
stop bye
come on man guys guys
you're going the wrong way trust me
[Music]
come on i'm setting traps for myself
dang it i'm just
[Music]
don't look at me this [ __ ]
god damn stop
[Music]
go chicken i died
i'm fifth i will not end this on last
i will not last hey
fourth place hell yeah that's actually
what i wanted
all right congrats i didn't see who won
well well played everyone there we go
rectorini nice
thanks for joining i'm gonna swap out
now
from party use the hashtag partygang
and uh epic times thanks for joining all
right
just give me a couple minutes and i'll
swap that
hell yeah that was fun
[Music]
this is really where my multitasking
skills comes into
perfect use because i don't know what
the [ __ ] i'm doing
uh all right party
all right if your name is noctis
i invite you if your name is
thick ass then i mean props to you well
done um
i'm inviting you clumsy cool
i'm inviting you
uh i am nathaniel i'm inviting you
[Music]
and one more
oh it's refreshing
d dick i'll remind you as well
i like the sprint racer but let's try
something else
[Music]
another race tnt race perhaps
sure
to be fair i didn't have any legs
it's kind of hard for me to run i was at
a disadvantage
okay let's get get it started
y'all in the chat as well i'm not doing
discord as well everyone keeps saying we
can't hear them but
it's just too much to connect at once
and i want to play with as many as i can
you know what i mean
this downloading
that says connecting to the ram hold up
it's gotta i just gotta download the
thingaroonie
oh
[Music]
someone was already in there but
i gotta download the resource pack
but i already downloaded it
there we go nope what is happening
there we go hey don't call me that
diedrick
don't do that
[Music]
how are you doing i called you ddrick
but i don't think that's your name
all right so what's this all about
[Music]
have you played this one daydream
good uh
so it's a race with tnt i assume
what it's a lever behind there
kind of says
[Music]
oh thanks
where what are you talking about doesn't
show up for me
well you're the only one that joined the
drake
oh there's a video okay i got you
let me go ahead and tell the people i'll
be right back
all right thick ass clumsy cool i am
nathaniel
get uh knocked his eggs
get in here i'll invite some more then
uh michaela schultz
maybe i shouldn't call you out you're in
by your name because then other people
might be spamming
that made no sense why would you do that
biff the banana
so my username is pewdiepie underscore
epic
see if you get a name knight from that
that's me
[Music]
and connect this one where am i
all right see i don't
it's so glitchy
[Music]
why why it's just putting me in a loop
i've already connected before
[Music]
what
just gotta wait
[Music]
now what
i'm switching
[Music]
we played dungeon dwellers i was so so i
would say
was combat cube fun yeah it was pretty
fun
let me in
sorry marx is writing me what a nerd
yes
oh my gosh
oh i'm in what that was it
i thought he like glitched that hey guys
floor again glad you guys made it hell
yeah
dude your banner is on backwards
that's trippy
all right so what was this again all
right everyone make sure you pick a
different team all right
hey thick gas you made it
[Music]
cool
okay i will go
does anyone one team pink because
otherwise i'm going for it no thick guys
already picked it
uh orange is taken sign is taken is
yellow taken
okay i'll go yellow it's okay
uh main street
let's go gamers
biff the banana what you got to connect
i invited you
diedrick is like hmm what should i pick
uh we kill each other basically
but wait i left the game
[Music]
should we wait for you biff
uh we'll play next round with you
ah don't shoot me right away god damn it
hey stop it stop it you're gonna regret
this
you're gonna you're gonna regret it stop
it stop it now
marios
what is this propeller helmet epic
don't don't don't don't
what do i get ender orb
yeah yeah what's your guy what's your
guy
what's your guy i have the high ground
you're up for blood aren't you hi
arrow shield ender orb
whoa i teleported that's so sick
whoa the guess is almost out of the game
this is unbelievable
thick ass is going to die thick ass
get thick guess not me all right i think
it's out sorry i think ash
it was over before it started honestly
[Laughter]
oh i got cloud in a bottle look at this
[ __ ] y'all you'll never get a chance now
oh it's game over oh someone already
figured that
i was chilling fair
yeah i don't even try it anakin
come on get him ah
where are you
you snake where are you
come out
is that where is he
there you are
ah cheating cheating cheating you're not
supposed to
stop it
get out of here get out of here get out
of here
oh sh
[Applause]
let's go
that was some anime [ __ ] hell yeah
well play guys not as good as me
unfortunately i don't want to rub it in
all right same same themes i guess
all right clumsy cool ones waterfall i'm
down for that
i'm gonna take a sip of my g fuel and
win now d
dick that's how that works
oh biff the banana you're not gonna win
drinking that [ __ ] that's unhealthy
all right starting off that guys has no
idea
the pain oh no thick ass oh no
not thick ass
nope hey hey don't team up don't team up
that's illegal
that's illegal you're teaming up this is
not cool
wait what i got spawn egg oh [ __ ] i got
a drill
what is the what is the drill dude
i don't know what i just stop it
oh lag
i don't know what's happening this is a
lot smaller matt
what up biff we homies right
no you're not homie
come on babe come on [ __ ]
come on biff come on bib come on [ __ ]
i will be back
you'll never kill me biff
i don't think so biffy oh my god there's
no floor left
oh yeah oh yeah
a beef got present for you
oh i throw it oh my gosh
where'd he go oh he's ceiling and
cringe cringe
get down from there oh oh
oh oh again he did it to him
he did it too oh [ __ ]
oh no where's your weapon babe huh
the trash talk
come down come down stop it come down
bro come down trust me come down you
want to come down
oh yeah oh yeah what are you talking to
me
that's how it goes it's minecraft that
life or death
oh no where's the floor now where's the
floor now he's in the spider web oh it's
looking bad
give me that
oh we're teaming up
oh [ __ ] that was close that one's going
for me now i don't know why
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
goodbye biff oh god he's got tnt he's
got [ __ ] tt stop him
all right later gamers adios
oh god he has propeller he's cheating
oh through the roof uh-oh
was not expecting that [ __ ]
okay nice
oh close game
oh biff the banana rest in peace
who's left oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'll be back
[ __ ]
no no draw draw
drop
not epic hey don't punch me
good game good game
all right one more
at least you didn't yeah i like this
game mode it's cool
wait someone pick yellow team hold up
what's left then
is red left yeah i'll pick red what what
do you want
huh
you want graveyard
but i want asian temple look how cool it
looks like mine minecraft thing
it's okay i was just going let's go here
you guys are so
[Laughter]
all nice is it lagging yeah obs
is lagging a little bit let me see is it
working better now
oh shoot this is a cool map actually
what is this turret okay
what does a drill do
don't punch me i'm swedish you fell for
it
oh [ __ ] i got the best item in the game
don't know what to do though [ __ ]
don't kill me i'm the region that does
not work
everyone knows that god damn
turret go
what in the world
go turret go turret
keep going turret dang it
bro don't hit me swedish
remember oh my gosh oh my gosh
what oh for phil harriman nice get out
of here
get out of here get out of here get
ow nice
oh
someone's behind me i don't like oh oh
this is bad
oh you got played thick ass
yeah your own game
he's got the cactus
come at me bro oh god
oh god oh nice i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry
no i'm i said i was sorry except apology
please
oh god i don't think that's gonna get me
up there
okay please
please please uh
get me up here yes yes yes yes yes he
has no idea
lift the banana my ground
[Laughter]
they don't know where i am
you can't stream snipe me you have no
idea
[ __ ] that
you weren't supposed to do that get out
of here
oh yeah oh yeah you think you're tough
no not my turret please
yeah get him turret yeah
get him oh no he's got propeller
oh he shot my turret oh that's all right
i got another one
they scared they scared
oh we lost someone
get him turret turret you're not doing
anything where'd he go
yes
you really wanna you wanna end it like
this oh he jumped down
okay
oh come on hey well played guys
well played hell yeah
all right i'm gonna swap bite you guys
any last word any last message
thanks for playing mother it was fun
swedish man kills his subscribers
sub to biff okay all right floor gang ow
cool all right
thanks guys all right switching out
gamers
so if you use the party thing party gang
i will now invite a couple more
let me just clear out
and let me just invite
oh post your minecraft name as well and
with the hashtag part again because
it just makes it easier for me to invite
rolex 22
captain emmett
[Music]
let me change music like i'm all happy
gaming
and sanitizer
uh that one drama kid
thorns
[Music]
uh
hell yeah thin meat
invited
should we [ __ ] around in creative a
little bit get a bunch of players in
see what happens
wait how would i do that
okay new world
super flat do i do that
crush the server how many people can you
do in a round
oh it takes a while hey i haven't had
much food yet let me just get a snack
and i'll be back in one minute
oh
oh the puggies are so cute
oh we got people in here already
i thought i picked superfly
what the [ __ ] could do
hold up let me reset it
[Music]
it's so slow
here we go alright everyone that i
invited
please try and connect to the realm
what up thorns all right wait wait wait
don't don't build anything yet
um how do i switch it to peaceful
you guys know the command to switch it
to peaceful
oh it's slash difficulty
there we go all right guys
are you ready for a building competition
no lag at all yeah building competition
all right
can you use any block you want i'm just
gonna look
turn over here and i'll give it two
minutes
i'll pick a theme
we are survival hey just go with it oh
my bad
i'm not showing the gameplay okay
i'll let chad pick a theme
and i'll judge each individual one all
right
all right first theme cobblestone
generator
you got two minutes go
you're in creative no oh you're not in
creative
well time to be creative
how do i switch i don't know how to
switch for everyone
[Music]
can you now type creative in command
okay
crazy
wait it looks like i have to unlock it
for every one of you
hold up all right don't cheat then
oh i can just have at all there we go
that's
nice thanks all right go
i'll observe from a distance
you got two minutes tick tock
is that too much time for a cobblestone
generator
i will base on aesthetics i will based
on functionality and overall
design
let's see if you guys finally think you
can build cobblestone generators better
than me
all right we got some lava we've got
some water going on
and i will also test it i will test each
individual one
i unironically don't know how to build
this one i need ken you need me
oh you know he was so messed up
there one more minute
all right we got some fancy stuff over
here all right
mine functions as a pool that's pretty
cool
double usage i will give extra points
for double usage
and stop stop that's two minute
time stop all right no one touch
anything no one thought shife you touch
disqualify
all right uh
rolex hey rolex 22
walk me through this
all right what do we got where's the
generator i mean
all right i guess i'll just judge it as
well while you tell me
i don't have time for lava fair enough
well it looks good
it looks cool i'll give you a
4 out of 5 for design no actually yeah
sure
let's go with that you try that's all
right um
i'll give you zero on functionality
because it doesn't work
so you uh you got you got four points
congratulations rolex well done all
right moving on
you're right that one drama kid don't
cheat
don't cheat i look at you hey captain
stop it stop it captain
all right talk me through this
what have we got
oh that's a lot of cobblestone wowie
okay all right i'm that the amount of
cobblestone is astounding
i don't think that's possible at five
out of five functionality i mean
no doubt about it but on design i gotta
give you a zero that
it looks god-awful does it regenerate
it does all right you gotta
uh wait who made this one i'm trying to
keep track
where are you that one drama kid
you get uh you get five congratulations
well done all right next one
thin meat what's up thin meat walk me
through this
cobblestone generator it's on fire
it's a hot tub ooh okay
i will definitely say bonus point for
the hot tub
it's a little it's a little high though
i don't know if i enjoy
enjoy uh drowning while i'm having a
huff top oh i see so this is where you
mine
excellent uh that's great functionality
okay i will give you four plus one
for the hot tub aspect design i think he
gets a three
it puts you at the highest
eight points thin meat well done
it's not as good as mine obviously
double cobblestone efficient oh
i didn't see that i didn't see that this
bonus point bonus points for double you
get nine points then meet well done
all right who's next what do we got over
here
captain emmitt walk me through this
yeah it works
i'll be the judge of that oh wow
it doesn't work alright it works
it works
[Applause]
it's named as well ultra mega couples
generally
uh what a i don't know how to rate this
to be honest
all right for name you get plus one
functionality i mean
i don't know how you can beat this
really five out of five obviously
so uh yeah it's not much it's honest
works you get six points well done
uh captain emit well done
hey margaret i saw you do something
i immediately retract one point minus
point so far
but i saw the swedish flag which is
worth at least three points
now so you'll you'll have one point
going in
it's nice i like it what do we got
all right minus five on
mertken minus five
congratulations minus five points that
is your rating
all right what do we got over here
all right this looks good designer i
like a lot
i would say a on the sign
who is this sorry who is this
who does this belong to goosey
where are you goosey
there you are all right
all right it's cozy i like it all right
and then you mine here
and it recharges what about here
recharges here
recharges amazing trip are you okay
within me
triple functionality i mean that's an
extra point
already we're up to four points plus
five nine points i'll give another point
because no you know what you're nine
goose it gets a nine well done
oh my bad
it's kind of cozy though really good job
was that all of them haven't forgotten
one why are their bats
no wait i haven't done this
my bad thorns
all right interesting design
what am i looking at here walk me
through the redstone
oh it pushes it forward to you
so it's got a time clock that as soon as
it generates a block
it pushes it forward and then i'll keep
pushing until it's got
that's cool nice
nice that's got to be at least three
extra points
uh design i'll give a
i mean using different blocks i'll give
it two
and functionality i mean that's a five
for sure
which brings you up to 10 point thorns
how do you do this in two minutes
connoisseurs
did anyone check him
two minutes no way all right
i retract one point for sus i know
that's not fair
but that's how that's how it goes which
means
on first place thin meat goose that
and thorn share it well done but
honestly i would say we're all winners
here
well done guys everyone jump in the lava
hell yeah well done that was fun
all right guys any last word i'm gonna
swap that sorry about the rick it's okay
i'm just joking
yours is really good too i like the
swedish plague
it's math related science i would say no
it's up to mr beast hell yeah good day
y'all
happy to play all the best guys thank
you for joining
all right swapping out again
that was fun we should do another
building competition i like that
um all right so le i'm gonna pick from
party
post hashtag party gang with your
minecraft username
and i will invite you
you guys are really funny it's fun
playing with you guys
make me laugh
this music however [ __ ] sucks
[Music]
uh
okay sorry music doesn't matter
all right awesome oakness i'm inviting
you
miber neighbor
meaner pose
shoes and
a game of steel style
cheese it bought
oh uh while i do this i should actually
reset the world
say i'm still picking people if you post
hashtag part again
using the link in description
using the site party not the chat gamers
come on
happy saturday hope you're all having a
great one
oh it's done all right let me see who's
online
only a gamer style awesome oakland's
neighbor get online minecraft i can see
you're not online and i invited you
uh
sebbies2254
does not exist
pops around
it's yazumi
[Music]
yes i mean okay
someone just died from slime
uh oh it's difficulty
welcome gamers welcome is that all
three people four people there we go
what's up gamers are you ready to get
creative
where are you going shoot zane
uh are we only four i might have more
hold up let me invite some more people
then
i'll bear back
death jester
invited you
epic hera
and q
and me
all right going back in
hey don't start building hey
stop it donna mog noah mogus stop it
i'll put an end to this shame on you
suzanne
shame go in the pit of shame now
jump in shoes in
go in the pit of shame
stop stop we have not started yet okay
all right you all will get credit mo
just stop
oh my god
all right what should they build now for
you get two minutes to build something
ocean facts no
automatic storage system i don't think
they can do that in two minutes
all right
okay i'll i'll keep it broad so you guys
can uh
pick whatever you want all right so i'm
gonna give you guys
you get two minutes as soon as i give
you all creative you get you can start
but after i say stop you gotta stop okay
um the theme
will be pewdiepie you can do anything
pewdiepie related
i'll judge by design how much it make me
haha
and bonus point
is always going to be there you know wow
me impress me
could be anything pewdiepie related you
all ready
start dancing if you're ready
all right it's all right it's just for
fun don't worry if you're doing terrible
all right three two one go
two minutes
start building
yep all right well maybe started
did the server just crashed what's
happening guys start building
[Laughter]
yeah go you got creative mode
she's a boss got a slam
start building start failing
all right again we're just gonna
all right it's a bit different from last
one but here all right
oh they they're picking their blocks i
understand
what's my lower go again
all right wait wait [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm gonna give you guys a little extra
time but it don't keep building
all right i want to cheat all right we
got the pewdiepie stuff there that's
interesting
all right i'm going to build my arm
what should i need
cue me you joined a bit late
excuse me i'll give you extra time if
you start building now right
it's okay we're doing pewdiepie related
theme
spell whatever you want i'll give you
extra time it's all good
you don't have to create it okay my bad
does this work
no
there we go
all right how much time 50 seconds left
gamers
50 seconds
[Laughter]
uh
this looks so bad
i'm glad i'm not competing
it's two minutes too low
all right i'm gonna give another that's
the timer that's the timer but i'll give
you guys a bonus
45 seconds
i'm just that generous
so
you done cheez-it
are you finished and stop
everyone except uh what was your name q
k q something uh sorry i don't remember
you can keep going all right
no more blocks no more blocks so what do
we got here
who's this shoe shoes on is this yours
is this miners who's this
you tried making my profile picture all
right that's kind of cool
[Laughter]
all right i'm just gonna give you five
because it's great
you get five
i like it
well done well done you said all right
who's this
jesus is this yours
that's all right thanks for playing
choosing bye bye
who is this
who is this who is this
no one wants to claim this she's it all
right cheesy walk it walk me through
what do we got what am i looking at
it's a tambourine
okay does it work
this september i like how you use the
pewdiepie
uh terra cotta that's definitely bonus
points
hell yeah
okay that's a nine you got a nine that's
beautiful
well done cheez-it i like it a lot
actually
well done and you were done quite early
so i'm going to give you a bonus point
for that
you got a 10. well done
all right moving on to
who is this blue thing
neighbor where are you there you are
try making a profit i can see i can see
the attempt
and it's not bad you don't have time i
i'll give you that i'll give you that
wait so did you do
i love pee pee pie as well or
this is all yours okay i gotta get bonus
for the love peepee pie
i saw i saw laid a solid six i would say
well done neighbor
a warm sex
nice all right moving on to oh we got
the pewdiepie
pattern and all the references who's
this
meaner pose oh
hey you even named them jurgen for 20
let's go okay
i like the gold as well very nice good
choice
not sure how to rate this not gonna lie
you know sven and jurgen is epic
obviously but you didn't
build them
but it also must have taken time out of
your design
um and i like the blue in the yeah hmm
how do i rate this
i would have given you an eight if it
was alabama on the throne instead of
sven but
i'll give you a seven
meter pose that's a seven
well done let's go
hell yeah well done all right moving on
what in god's earth do we have here
all right how is this who is this
cue me cue me is this yours
who is this who is this
a gamer cell where are you come close
they
don't worry there you are all right walk
me through this
explain explain what i'm looking at here
because i'm trying to understand what
i'm looking at
looks like you try to do a clock
is that correct i think a random chicken
walked in
oh so it's not supposed to be a chicken
in there
oh there okay you can also do that you
can also do that
well any gamer knows you got to block it
off on one side otherwise you're going
to push it
but it's fake all right that's
that's definitely a bonus point for fagi
that's an old school reference
gamer cell i will have to give you uh
um
i think if you didn't bother oh sorry
sorry i'm so sorry but it didn't work
anyway i think if you didn't do any of
this
i think i would have seemed more
deliberate but um
yeah that's a that's a five point
nothing well done nice i like it
actually 5.1 you get bonus point for
fagi
chat thinks i should rate you higher but
um
yeah talk to chad i guess i don't know
all right moving on
all right epic harass is you
okay who is this okay it is a guy
nice we went for the brofist very nice
and oh i thought that was like an egg or
something
and small pepe oh no one thought of that
that's so minimalist
i love that holy [ __ ] you should have
just done that and i would have given
you a 10.
but this is cool too i guess
all right i would have given you a
probably a
four or a five but uh for small peepee
that's
that's a lot of extra points i'm gonna
give you uh six
well done who was it abikara that was
you nice well done great job
small pp that was genius
hey what can i say i'm a harsh i'm a
harsh critic
all right who did pog
hear me you did pog
how was that a pewdiepie reference you
have 10 seconds
before i burn it down
[Laughter]
well you do have the the pattern but uh
you should know never pog pewdiepie
never pop pewdiepie you get the lowest
score out of all
i'm sorry qme i'm sorry i hate to do
this to you
but you got four you get a four and i'm
also going to burn one piece because
that's how much i don't like it
but i do appreciate the pattern oh it's
raining
so it's not all bang i think you no no
that looks so sad it's okay
it's okay you did good was that
everyone's
did i miss anyone
okay epic that means the winner is
chi said with a beautiful tambourine was
it
jesus did you make the tambourine who
did i rate a 10
congratulations
well done
well done honestly you all were great it
made me laugh
every one of them
thanks for playing guys
[Laughter]
well done any last word thanks for
joining
bling blanc let's go
now now maybe i'm gonna retract points
from you you're fine now
oh a gamer style actually i'm gonna give
you a point for that you're 6.1 now
you put in a hole but why
don't ruin it put it back
all right
never exit rar never all right
i'll do one more round post hashtag
partygang
and your microwave username and i'll
invite you for another round
of minecraft creations
uh let me just reset the world
there we go
party gang
so basically i'll invite you and then
you'll join my realm
that's how it works
suddenly the tambourine looks hella sexy
they'll make it weird
all right i gotta invite people my bad
all right here we go ex lux
invited
derp the buddy invited
does not exist
derp the buddy
i definitely wrote it right i
toot
uh pops around
no you gotta be yava edition sorry
gamers i don't know if it works cross
ram i'll try and invite you and maybe it
works actually
pops around
uh land and bs
doesn't exist
i'm a failure 101 nice name
uh we're on yellow edition gamers
best body 21.
and marshall marlin
only three of these are actually online
so i'll keep in mind
[Music]
i'm not going through that many guys so
if you want to join us
party party gang
uh night owl 77
couple more yeah boy razor
spot ominous all right that should be
enough more than plenty we're a lot of
people now
oh [ __ ] my bad gamers
welcome welcome
yo you got slime slime hurt
all right we need a new theme now
okay i think i got a theme
when you do you feel cups coming out i
don't know bro
[Laughter]
hey marshall if you win i'll send you
one
hollow let's go
hey don't punch me all right at the plex
minus one point already
i'm watching you you're minus one i'm
remember
pewdiepie will remember that
nice do i get extra points for being
swedish
no no there's no nationalism in this
all right now we're even at the plex
you're down to zero
all right
the theme is simple
the theme is do i get minus points for
being over unit
well you want minus points excellent the
theme is meme
all right i'm gonna give you guys a
little more time
four minutes and 44 seconds
the theme is meme as soon as i
make you all creative you get to start
alright
there we go ready
three two one go
starting the timer four minutes and 44
seconds
you have to think this is the problem
no everyone's picking blocks they're
panicking
our contestants are nervous
they got the pressure
let me clean this and what is this
don't overthink it
i will judge on funny i will judge also
an aesthetic
equally important equally important
spot ominous has not started how much
time i'll tell you every minute it's
been one minute so far
oh what is happening
all right i don't want to i want to
cheat
now i can fly
look at that guys feels good
netherride looks so much cooler when
it's not enchanted
all right it's been another minute you
got two minutes and 30 seconds left
if you're panicking i will give you
another minute
but we'll shall see it's not that
difficult is it
please
i guess i'm more desperate
homie just chilling
oh
uh you don't know how to get block you
press e to get blocks pops around i
can't
uh
if you actually haven't figured out how
to get a block now i'll give you some
more time i can't tell if you're
trolling
i'm a failure just join all right i'm a
failure the theme is meme
i'll give you extra time
oops oops
all right you got one more minute guys
oh you're still in survival my bad hold
up i'll give you another extra minute
got one minute and 30 seconds
uh and then i got to do a separate timer
for you i'm a failure
there you go
air sheep they learn how to airbend
since they were born
any questions
they were so close to water but they
refused to touch
hey all right
15 14.
uh oh [ __ ] i can't run
10 more seconds
time on everyone except
i'm a failure stop stop blocks damn
i want to see no more blocking
no more blocks no more blocks i'm a
failure oh you're okay actually sorry
okay all right where did we start let's
start over here
let me just write down the points i
remember
all right we have pops around
pops around all right what do you got
explain
you don't know how to make okay
you want to walk me through this pops
around
am i missing the mean
all right give me any help here because
it's a t-pose
okay that doesn't mean you are right
all right
um i appreciate the pewdiepie colors
and tipos is a meme so i will give you
three points well done actually yeah i
do appreciate the simpleness of it
i'll give you four well done pops around
all right moving on to what i am god's
earth is this
marshall is this you why explain this
who is this come up to me if you're uh
uh after plex after plex where are you
i wish i knew what it was
can you make something up
all right marshall you failed
i'll give you one point for the
randomness of it
oh sorry marshall i said after plex i
have to plex i have the plagues
sorry marshall sorry marshall
all right one one point for randomness
i'll give you that
all right moving on what on god's earth
is this
mine says curse furby
oh god it is i even got the disgusting
cucumber blocks who is this
after flight was like i got one score
i'm out
i only know pewdiepie means good that's
even bonus points for that
it gets banned from premises i can't
spell
actually satan demon
itunes all right i2 that's a nine
well done
amazing i dude very funny
all right moving on to
[Laughter]
uh warning i appreciate the warning
who is this uh how do i read your name
wemilly women live amazing
i immediately got what it was didn't
need to read a sign even
oh emily my bad all right uh
yeah very well done
emily i'm gonna give it an eight it's on
point
it's it's uh
self-explanatory you know it's a modern
piece of art really
i will say
very nice well done emily all right
moving on let's go over
where do we go here oh we got peppa the
frog
uh i lost the ability to build
feels bad man
i'm blind hey i mean it looks real i'll
give points for that
i don't know why i said real um
i'll give this uh is it better than pops
around
hmm yeah probably i don't know i'll give
it a
i'll give it a four five [ __ ] it
four
oh that's the alarm for uh whoever
joined before
uh you have to stop building unless you
haven't already
all right nice one razer
i panicked so take a huge spongebob
oh okay not bad
kind of like it okay you got done great
[Laughter]
hell yeah extra points for g field for
sure
i think spongebob would be friends
remember yes perfect i think so too
sorry who built this
guys you gotta probably present it
because otherwise i have no clue
i couldn't connect it i feel like i'm so
crazy spot ominous spot ominous where
are you
get over here there you are hello well
done
i love it that's an a
8.5
8.5 right there well done
i love it
sometimes panicking is good it worked
out great
all right moving on over here who is
this
is that stefano
what am i looking at i went for an old
me
but it still checks out x logs
that's cute marshall
barrel and stefanie oh
oh hell yeah
hold up this is so good i gotta throw
money at it
i don't know why what is stefano doing
on a barrel
conquering him obviously
i don't know wait
xlx uh gonna give it a
what should i give it i don't know
another eight
you did really good i love the design
it's creative
and it took me back to old times well
done
all right moving on
what on god's earth is this would it be
a nine if i could
if you could blow it up i'm not going to
blow up stefano that would be
sacrilegious
but wait wait there's a plot twist no no
no no no you're building
you should have thought of that before
too late x lux i'm sorry
but if you had a second layer to the
meme i would have been impressed
okay wait sorry what what's here uh what
was that
wait
i hit the sign okay fair you can put the
sign again
i'll look away
yeah next round i'll tell you guys to
put your sign next to it
you should have all right is it done
edgar
peeing in
edgar why are you doing this
hold up i can't see cause uh
i mean it definitely looks like edgar
the face is on point
i gotta look from this angle oh
god damn it
all right laugh then design
i don't know eight maybe but so that i
guess that brings you down to uh
a nine
was that marshall i don't remember
chat loved it though
if you nailed the design more i would
easy ten easy pen
uh all right moving on yeah boy ray now
wait who
joined less again i keep forgetting you
know there's so many names
was i'm a failure that's right hey
i'm gonna give you one point already for
the jojo skin so you already have one
extra point
what am i looking at is this a meme
okay let me see the sign uh cat lady
it looks like an ogre with two heads i'm
very confused
oh i got it i got it i got it
all right pointing at the cat very good
[Laughter]
i mean it's gorgeous i mean how did i
not see that
right off the bat i i don't know
all right i'll give it a seven but uh
that puts you up at eight
for the jojo's skin
you get an eight i'm a failure well done
well done and really funny
is that all of them
y'all smashed it y'all killed it but the
winners
are i toot
and uh marshall
i think i was a little biased oh wait
the spongebob one was so good too
okay those are my favorite i'm just
gonna say that yeah but i like them all
could i still get a cup i don't know how
to set that up
if i could i would definitely would
good job guys well done any last words
i'm gonna retract half a point from
marshall
just because uh i don't know how to send
you a cup unless
someone could do it g-fuel if you're
watching this send marshall a cup
can i get okay all right this is not
anyway thanks for playing guys
[Laughter]
well done well done well done it's all
right i'm sorry i said that if i didn't
keep my promise i just don't know how to
do it
alright thanks for joining all the best
guys
you promised these no see you next time
hell yeah
it's a mr peace giveaway
all right one more ryan final round
use the party in the description
i'm just gonna pee really quick
uh
so
the egg rp one was so funny
i actually i get p1 should have won
all right
gonna invite people now for the last and
final round
meet masseuse that is a name that i read
out loud
party gang parties
uh
lord carrot x
made that's the thing you guys need to
be online
on java edition to play john fitz mad
lips
is that your name
doesn't exist you have to post your
minecraft username
katsunaksu
the beyblader 789
shirley senpai
toshi
the minister 650
less than
golden's eagle
kylie boo i'm gonna get a lot of players
in this one
sabs79 all right that's it
let's go
okay
we need a theme for the last one hey
swedish skin props
hell yeah oops
putting it back
oh no that's what happens meet me zeus
no take it out of the box
that's all right
uh i invited you but how do i join uh
click on the realm on
minecraft java
shirley senpai in the house
is that thanos nice hey what's up
hey you made it
it's all right uh
prosthetics don't ask too many questions
[Laughter]
it's all right i will only judge you as
harshly as i possibly can
so don't worry about it
what should be the theme though i
haven't figured out yet
what if i don't build anything and say
here it's invisible i mean that's a
choice
all right well keeping the theme uh vega
vague again so you guys can do whatever
you want i want to see some nice
floor gang themed creations
the theme is floor gang
is that under everyone got that
as soon as i someone left
as soon as i give you all creative um
you can start building uh also put a
sign before your creation i will give
you a little bit more time than before
so put a sign before it so i know who
made it in front of it
okay here we go
find how much five minutes six minutes
six minutes i'll give you six minutes
go floor gang the theme is floor game
give them 10 is that not a bit much
[ __ ] it 10 minutes then what else [ __ ]
am i gonna do for 10 minutes
fine ten minutes but then you better
impress me
no pressure no pressure
10 minutes is a long time but they
should get some sick creations
we want to see the top of the cream tier
game
the best of the best
what are you lord carol you're not doing
anything
oh my god the theme is flora gang
two minutes has passed
floor gank floor gang floor gang build
floor game
this is so nice
all right keep forgetting they thank you
hmm
we do this in sweden it's a tradition
every midsummer
oops
we just like dance in front of the lava
it's really cool
oh it's on fire [ __ ]
oh the first one to die
gets to send to floor floor realm
who's next i wonder
the last one standing will be granted
immortality
it's taking longer
come on guys this floor get oh
no someone bit the dust
oh horses just make me sad i'm not gonna
look at it
all right you guys have five minutes
left
five minutes
think what you can do in five minutes
oh looks like oh oh oh
looks like we have a win there we have a
chosen no
no he was so close to greatness come to
me
water water no wheat
uh
heal heal the chosen one heal him
you're the chosen one you cannot fall
ah that was close
um
you won hurray
you get to live for a thousand years
this is so awesome
you you obtained the souls of your
predecessors i really it was rigged i
mean it was higher up than the others
i just realized but congratulations
how does it feel wow
there you go it is done
now be
what the hell he survived lava for three
years
oh my god
i can't believe it
i thought what
he was going to live forever man oh my
god i keep seeing the chair so cool
a thousand years go quick i guess [ __ ]
all right let's talk to our contestants
how's it going over here lord karate
cool all right you guys have two minutes
and 30 seconds left
time to do those finishing touches
two minutes left
y'all can do it
get your head in the game
god damn
there you go
oh we got someone using diamonds okay
one more minute oh no no no [ __ ]
one more minute
no don't move
you're trapped here
don't move
ten don't forget to put your name in the
sign nine
eight seven six
five four three
two one everyone stop building
if you keep building from this point if
i see a single blocks i will delete
points
all right let me just kill him
whoa what a cool sound
why won't you die you're evil foul
creature
all right you can place the sign if you
haven't
there we go all right here we go
let's start with this because i saw this
before and it's gorgeous
beautiful this is made by toshi
toshitoshitoshi
all right pewdiepie chair is still floor
gang that is
true that is true i just realized i
[ __ ] up the color scheme
it i mean it looks beautiful i don't
know what you mean [ __ ] that
it's gorgeous too lazy to fix it swedish
flag for example
i was just about to give you extra
points for swedish flag
well done it's beautiful i like the
little swirl you got there it's almost
like a
the chair is floor gang i'll get points
for creativity
and design that's a solid 7.5 well done
toshi very nice
let me just try it actually let me see
if i like it
oh it's a lot it's a little stiff
it's a little harder than i thought i
might have to retract uh
a little points 7.4 actually
could have made it softer but well done
well done but whoa what
what is this the alliance of big peepee
and small pp
i represent swedish floor game pp manor
if i lose snap
all right we're getting threatened by
meat masseuse
[ __ ] all right well
well we don't know we don't know what's
gonna oh i see these are
peeping glass here all right very nice
and then how explain the alliance i
don't get it
the corners are pv i got that i got that
i got that
i like that i like the minimal pp it's
cool we have seen that once before
though
but i do appreciate it
in this day of age of hate uh huh
that's it okay i'm gonna give it a
big peeping small piece we're good to go
okay okay okay okay
i'll give it a six well done i
appreciate all the themes
the swedish flag and the small pp and
big pp
i feel like the contrast between big pp
small pp is something that you could
have worked on
and it would have been more impactful
but there you go
all right moving on to whatever that all
right this one's leaking out
what is this this is
sorry about the annoying villagers house
kylie
ceiling gang burns floor gang thrives
oh [ __ ] they're so rich down here
oh my god it's such a great community of
families i totally see it
and oh they're just oh that's awful
oh that's terrible i wouldn't want to be
sailing gang that would be
pretty cringe all right you played the
contrast which is just
beautiful amazing
this is excellent
kylie you got an eight point
two well done kylie
couldn't have done it better myself
all right what do we got here made us
a thing okay made us a thing
nice decimal yeah all right what a what
what is beauty okay thanks for spelling
my name correct
and it's oh it's me as a floor
i get it oh my god it's beautiful
it really hit the attention to detail
i can tell press the button i'm sorry
what
where are you
you're going to put a sticky piston
there hold on
there you go there you go
fix it for you oh man that's a nice
detail
why is that why is it a small pp made is
a thing
why is this why so small
i'm gonna have to retract point uh
6.111
and infinity
well done i wouldn't have guessed it was
me i don't think it looks like me enough
plus i had to fix it as well so i'm
gonna retract one one so it's only 7.11
now
but not bad not bad all right moving on
uh sorry who made this katsuna
all right uh what do we got we got one
oh okay nice cute
pretend this is a temporary
that's points for creativity right there
i i do think that is september
you panic is this supposed what is it
supposed to be
explain because i'm not sure if i got
all of it except the tambourine
and it's the lovely floor
what okay
it's very nice i like it and this is
edgar
a minimalistic edgar look at that that's
so cute
definitely plus for style definitely
plus for minimalism
and overall the tambourine i mean that
just lift the whole thing up
so i'm gonna give this a 7.51
well done katsuna
very good all right moving on
here we have hey uh wait a minute
i thought i said floor gang not
wall gang sabs 97
what is this explain explain this sabs
why is it not a floor
[Laughter]
there's floor up here oh that's a good
point i didn't think of that
wall gang but built different
a traitor amongst us question more why
is the wall
bigger than the floor though hmm it is a
good brofist
i'll give you that and we have
small peepee as well melon small peepee
wouldn't possibly understand the
reference
but i do um i'm
not bad not bad i'll give it a 6.9 well
done
well done very nice
all right moving on to what is this
charlie senpai
i present floor i'm sorry i don't build
i think the sign that presents it
actually helps a little bit
there's a hole in the floor
why is there a hole in the floor explain
that that's definitely minus point
i don't think floors should i have holes
in them
he got me garsh darn it infinite floor
oh oh that's another way to look at it
wait what
no no
[Laughter]
that's great that's so great that's
funny 7.8
well done
had me at the first half i'll give you a
nice well thought
i'm out of disappointed all right moving
on
very nice very nice john fitz
one two three uh all right not sure if i
follow what's happening here
it says it this way
yes i'm spitting out the floor i'm
spitting
out the floor oh i spit at the ceiling
okay of course
that's [ __ ] great john fitz
amazing 7.9
john fates 0.911 and why i'm being so
careful with the scoring but that's
amazing
the attention to detail on the spit
is amazing very creative
you know that's a solid eight i i can't
i can't hold back the eight on that one
well done
spirit at the ceiling very nice very
nice
i believe unless i forgot someone that
that was old
am i right am i wrong
that means and no
that means meet mrs is going to flip
because he lost
and the winner is john feeds 133
but honestly they were all [ __ ] great
so many made me laugh well done
you're all the winners hurray
well done
sorry you gave me an 8.2 today no i
didn't
oh kylie won my bad kylie won
kylie won where are you kylie you're
right i give him an iphone
we showed us kylie is it this one
[Music]
yeah kylie won kylie you won yeah
i'm such an idiot
sure me you want to you know uh she's
manipul no i wrote it down
i wrote down 8.2 i didn't see it my bad
rest in peace john
all right thanks for playing guys any
last word any shout outs go ahead
oh golden seagull you're late my dude
well play
that's so fun
hell yeah thank you charlie
you guys are so funny i really liked it
come on that's it
uh thanks for joining the stream guys
that was so funny
shout out to party for sponsoring it and
helping me hook
up with you guys connect with gamers
it's a great service
oh man
the link is in the description if you
want to try it out any game you can play
with all the gamers
connect with other bro gang members
broking yeah let's go with that
find cool people to play with use the
hashtag pewdiepie whatever if you want
to
connect with people the same interest
it's cool oh wow thanks for the shout
out john that's so cool
and uh yeah thanks to everyone for
watching hope you had fun
see you next time bye bye bye bye
you